leur voisine sao le boulot mende une
lapdance table 5 le col pas trop lemay
qui pue la pisse et en plus il a un
crochet et pas un voisin est un dealer
david classe g un chouïa de marie jeanne
qui attend mexique rapporte le mois
d'ici dimanche soir je te paierai cent
mille dollars
trop balèze pour moi tu n'as pas le
choix c'est quoi ça j'ai acheté une
orque je gagne beaucoup d'argent
ils ont sûrement vous fouillez à la
frontière vous pourriez vous déguiser
bein dans batman mon truc comme ça ça te
dirait de faire dix mille dollars ont
dit non c'est pas du deal c'est de la
contrebande moi je passe la frontière
tout seul énorme drapeau rouge
mais les amis ça les regarde même pas
alors j'ai besoin que tu sois ma famille
j'ai engagé cet abruti qui habite mon
immeuble et unique sonne au sdf
kenny voilà la nouvelle salle j'ai
toujours voulu une seule elle aime moi
cette chose il suffit qu'on joue à la
famille américaine super pro pratique
s'est présenté mais ce sont mes
meilleurs chez rita abbey golf
je suis venu récupérer un petit chouya
double
ça c'est pas un petit chouya donc fait
transporter assez terne pour enfumer une
colonie de restaurer la coopérative
montblanc vous pouvez campé avec le fitz
gerald cette nuit quand on est marié
depuis si longtemps on a envie d'épicés
un peu les choses
ce n'est encore jamais touché une autre
femme je serais partant pour ça alors en
échange
oui
[Musique]
votre famille c'est un skateboard aux
têtes blondes génial un skateboard mais
vingt grosses bêtes noires
moussa kerry s'est fait mordre par une
tarentule [ __ ] de bordel ça fait trop
mal
alors qu'elle regarde brin amer butt ton
pantalon
on a tous déjà vu une quinzaine à
toulouse c'est comment je peux me
regarder
[ __ ] de merde se passent les choses
bien gardé ce truc non je peux regarder
ses manches à quel point kenny va très
bien en fait dont la volée un trafiquant
international
vous allez tous mourir en famille ma
femme non c'est une strip teaseuse
hockey khl bleus
[Musique]
m
un peu de respect c'est un maire de
réfléchir un peu
[Musique]